money itself has a program written
inside as smart contract which kind of
like defines
um how much money the person that owns
the money can use and if the money is
blocked in certain cases or where the
money could be used and on what kind of
things okay so theoretically you can
with with smart contracts
um program the money in a way that that
you could say okay you've um I don't
know what used up um your quota of
cigarettes or flights for that matter
then your money isn't going to be
working
um anymore that you could program that
it's fairly simple to do that right
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside of Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctek
hello everybody and welcome to another
episode of 20 minute leaders today I'm
with me RAV was chosen as one of the 100
most inspiring women in blockchain 2020
with more than 20 years of experience in
finance technology and creating
award-winning fintech Innovation meravi
is a world-known fintech blockchain
digital disruption future of Finance
investment and trading interfaces expert
she was named one of 36 top women
revolutionizing crypto 2022 worldwide by
techround UK and twice chosen for the
women in fintech power list by innovate
Finance UK mayrov specializes in
Innovative Technologies and their impact
on the future of banking Finance money
regulations macro economics and
businesses as a director at Excellence
trade and Excellence investment house
may Rob is a sought after advisor and
international keynote speaker on
blockchain fintech 5G nft metaverse the
feature of money Finance Banking cbdc
cryptocurrencies and digital disruption
she teaches consult
[Music]
welcome to 20 minute leaders thank you
so much for being here how are you
thank you for the invitation I'm great
how are you
wonderful you're a recognized expert in
fintech blockchain webstery and
everything in between just before we
started here you were telling me a
little bit about your upcoming travel
plans and I got a headache so it's a
it's quite it's quite an interesting
position to be in you know in 2022
um you mentioned a little bit about how
excited you are about this evolutionary
step that we're in and and the different
things that are happening and so over
these 20 minutes I'm going to pick your
brain over these transformational
changes how these different Technologies
are impacting different systems in our
lives and how things are evolving and
changing as you see them so again thank
you for being here and I'd love to start
a little bit with your own background
where are you coming from that that led
you to be so excited and passionate
about this space
um so it's actually that two Geeks of
mine kind of like uh became a thing
um uh you know I've been in the finance
and technology for over 20 years and
I've um managed to combine the two
before the name fintech was even created
I started out as a programmer at when I
was eight years old actually I started
programming and I continued programming
um till um during the.com era and when
that Bubble Burst uh finding myself uh
with um you know a baby and Pregnant uh
I had to find another subject that was
interesting and I went into becoming an
investment consultant by
um a licensed Investments consultant by
the Israeli security Authority and
um I did that for a few years and then I
combined the two
um as a product and business manager of
Lumi trade one of the biggest security
trading websites in Israel I did that
for seven years and
um around five years ago I kind of
entered um the blockchain space as um
you know it's for me it's just like a um
you know cryptocurrency though just
another a whole set of asset classes
that you know they they're in the
process of being uh um regulated but you
know it's just more assets and on the
other hand blockchain is just another
kind of database it's just you know
decentralized and has its up so you know
it's upsides and it's downsides so for
me it was a very natural transition and
um during the last um
five years I've been working with um
Banks Regulators governments companies
startups individuals
um on everything that
um has to do with the moving ahead I'd
say with with these Technologies I was
the CEO of a few blockchain um uh
companies I'm a director at Excellence
one of the biggest security trading
investment houses
in Israel and
um
I was awarded a few times for uh one of
the women leading women in fintech in
London and uh
um I was chosen a few months ago as one
of the 36 women revolutionizing crypto
in the world so um and I'm very
passionate about you know what's
happening because I see it as uh you
know for looking kind of like a
historical perspective we're kind of
like seeing I'd say the next step in the
human evolution in the in the fields of
finance and uh and it's very interesting
to see
um the different Dynamics and power
struggles that are happening kind of
like behind the scenes but they're
they're kind of like pushing and they
could be pushing in different directions
on you know what's the future of money
what's the future of Finance uh who's
going to be owning um the data because
you know as you and I know data is is
you know it was named as the as the new
oil right
um so who's gonna be owning that who's
going to be monetizing that is it going
to be
um centralized entities like the big
Tech like what we're seeing right now
and governments or is it going to be the
individuals that are going to be holding
their own data
um and monetizing it themselves like you
know in the and what we you know I'd
call it the ideology of web3 right so
it's very interesting to see kind of
like where things pan out and the power
struggles happening behind the scenes of
um
um uh you know and everything that has
to do with the future of uh of of money
and ownership and all the rest of uh all
of the rest of these for me interesting
stuff
what's your take on on what's Happening
Now you know so my thesis perspective I
think this but the mirror the fact that
you're calling it an evolution obviously
or you're coming into the space from a
very optimistic standpoint what's you
know over the last few years we've seen
a lot of conversation around sort of the
philosophy of what's happening and this
evolutionary step
um how how do you see it evolve you know
currently where where are we at what are
the different challenges presented and
what what is sort of the evolution that
you expect for us to have with fintech
in regards to web3
so I think that what's happening
kind of like um
under the surface is that there are two
kind of ideologies that are on a path of
uh of uh of I'd say kind of like
choosing between them and you can see
when when they kind of like Collide and
when that happens and
um and it's interesting to kind of like
look at the Dynamics because on the one
hand we have
um I'd call it the traditional finance
and the power structures that that we're
used to having for the last 100 200 300
years where you have
um centralized entities starting with
central banks and Banks and um lately um
to this to these centralized entities
the big Tech
um companies kind of like uh joined in
and on the other hand you have an
ideology that started with Bitcoin
itself but kind of like you know grew
and grew it's kind of like a ripple
effect of of of people that come and say
wait we're kind of like tired of these
Central entities and we think that the
power should be shifted into the hands
of the individuals in various ways
um you know that the basic way or the
first way was you know with Bitcoin
itself saying okay money doesn't
necessarily need to be that I'm created
by centralized entities when managed by
centralized entities it could be
um done
um uh you know by by people working
together on some sort of uh of Ledger or
or some sort of consensus where people
agree to each other and kind of evolved
and evolved to the point where this
money can be programmed with smart
contracts and data comes into the
picture and the ownership of data comes
into the picture and the new generation
of this ideology is web 3 that comes and
says well you know if data is something
that's worth so much money and the tech
Giants are making so much money off it
doesn't it make more sense or isn't it
more I'd say fair or ethical that the
individuals creating the data themselves
would be the ones holding the data and
monetizing it okay and and and then if
you look at these two forces you see
them kind of like you know they you know
a few years ago I gave a lecture on one
of the stages and that was I think like
uh actually before the uh the blockchain
bubble of 2017-18
um burst I was talking I was saying you
know like kind of like I work in Two
Worlds and they even speak different
languages I work in the traditional
Financial world you know I've worked
there for 15 years right in a bank and
um and I said I'd buy banks on the new
technologies and Innovation with fintic
and everything and on the other hand I
work in the blockchain sphere where I'm
bringing I think that the organized
methods and kind of like the traditional
kinds of ways of doing
um um of uh you know of having
regulation all the rest of it and
bringing that into into the blockchain
space and these spaces don't even talk
to each other and if you look if you
talk to any of the sides each side is
going to say why do we need those and
why do we need those right and they even
call Money different things these guys
called Fiat and these guys call it money
and you know so I was kind of like
waiting for these two worlds to kind of
like I would I was thinking they would
combine into one which would create the
next step um in finance but what I'm
seeing you know fast forward four years
um I'm kind of like seeing that
it's not I don't think it's going to be
combined so fast because I think that
right now there's kind of like an
ideological
um uh um I'd say even a struggle between
um these two ideologies and it's very
interesting to see which way the future
will take us right because there's power
struggles and there's obviously a lot of
money involved right and um and
different interests
um uh so that that's my take on on
what's Happening and um and the question
is which ideology is going to kind of
like uh take the masses and and and
produce I'd say the next
um uh generation of money because if
we're talking about the centralized
entities the direction that that is
going to is to Central Bank digital
currencies which are um the new version
of um of of of the money that we know
only in the digital version which means
that the money can be programmed and
there are questions around privacy we
can touch upon that and if on the other
hand the decentralized as
ideologies will win then that means that
it's a big question that's disrupting
the whole financial and monetary system
that we've been you know born into and
that had been has been around for the
last hundred years of central banks and
the banking system and um uh and there
are implications to both sides and you
know and it's kind of like is it going
to be a bumpy ride and uh and what's
gonna you know what's what's gonna be
what's gonna happen after this bumpy
ride right because right now it looks
like they're they're in a collision
course
what's been happening over the last four
or five years that what what shifts have
you noticed in the market in the
perception either more philosophically
um culturally or tangibly well what has
been some major shifts over the last
four or five years that could give us an
indication as to the path that we are
expecting to take in this webstery space
okay so I think that that what's
happening is that
um the technology is moving so fast and
the then the use cases that can be built
upon this technology are moving
even faster and what's um kind of like
uh lagging behind or where the struggle
is at is is on the ethical and
ideological
point of view okay
um if I'm looking at at what's happening
with um with the um traditional Finance
then as I said you know um the
technologies that have been actually
invented for decentralization are being
adopted by the centralized entities but
in a in a way that kind of like takes
the ideology out and leaves only the
technology and the use case and I'm
talking about Central Bank digital
currencies that um that um you know use
Smart contracts which ethereum kind of
invented right but they use them in a
centralized way which means that the new
versions of Central Bank digital
currencies can be programmed that means
that they can um theoretically
um and there are there are um use cases
of this already happening in um in
different areas of of the world where
the money itself has a program written
inside as smart contract which kind of
like defines
um how much money the person that owns
the money can use and if the money is
blocked in certain cases or where the
money could be used and on what kind of
things okay so theoretically you can
with with with smart contracts
um program the money in a way that that
you could say okay you've um I don't
know what used up um your quota of
cigarettes or flights for that matter
then your money isn't going to be
working
um anymore that you could program that
it's fairly simple to do that right
um and in one of the pilots that that
that China has done
um this was done okay that the money was
programmed and and not only that it
wasn't the the the program did not
enable people to save the money that
means that if they didn't use it up in a
certain amount of time okay then the
money was taken from their wallet
because it's a smart contract you can do
you can program anything that you want
right so that's one of the developments
that's kind of like happening
um from the one side of the you know of
the of the traditional Finance I'll call
that and on the other hand you have
um um the the evolutions of of ideas
um and and technology that enable
actually people to hold on to their data
and control
um um uh what they do with their money
and their data in in a more um
significant way and I'm talking about
um for instance nfts okay nfts have been
used for the last two years it was a
whole like you know kind of like uh
there was a hype around it but in the
fields of art right but
um but art is not the only use case that
you can use nfts for okay nfts are
actually you know they're actually smart
contracts right again programmed um
tokens
um and and and and the next generation
of nfts are not necessarily going to be
in and what they won't have to do with
with the art necessarily and I'm talking
about
um for instance
um the nft that Alfa Romeo created for
their Denali car wouldn't car what they
did was that for each car that came out
they created an nft that holds the data
of the owner and how much gas and
mileage the car has been using it you
know it was serviced and if there was a
car accident and if a person sells them
the car to the next um uh holder of the
car right it's actually that the NF team
moves on to the next person now this is
very interesting in regards to the next
generation of nfds because a this again
disrupts centralized entities of who
keeps track of who owns cars right and
second of all it opens new opportunities
for companies doing this let's say for
instance theoretically Alpha Romeo when
she when they enable
um the the nft to transfer hands from
one hand to the other they could you
know they could start participating in
the secondary Market of cars which is
something which is a new Revenue stream
that did not exist until nft came into
the picture right
so um if we're looking at and again I'm
taking it to this side of the
decentralized Technologies and what
humanity is creating we're seeing more
and more um ideas and and
implementations of of how technology can
enable new revenue streams and uh new
control over over people's own data and
you know so so these are kind of like
the things that are happening and it's
got like happening in parallel and you
know each one is this developing
um their own um uh I'd say solutions
that that that match their interests and
at some point it's it's gonna have to
kind of like meet and and and raise
questions of okay so we understand this
happening on Sidelines this is happening
behind the scenes
the moment that it surfaces I think that
all humanity is going to have to have
make a decision of okay where is this
going are we going to be going into a
more centralized place where money is
programmed and privacy is in there is is
is is is not existent for for private
individuals and um and it's only in the
hands of tech Giants and and um uh
governments and um and uh the
traditional Finance world or are we
going to be to the other side of it
um where um where people are going to
have I'd say uh more ownership on their
data and companies are going to have
more um
I'd say I'm uh um abilities to create
new revenue streams based on this data
and liability for them to come and uh
and I'd say program and tokenize uh what
they're creating
I hope that they weren't clear enough
a clear on one hand raises a lot of
questions on the other hand who are the
main decision makers
Personnel that are going to Define these
strategies long term
in your opinion
um so I I would say that
you know
um again traditionally obviously uh the
definition of of of
um what's being created is is regulators
and governments and um
and I'd say them the traditional
um Power structures that that we're
aware of on the other hand the I think
that the new technologies enabled the
masses to kind of communicate with each
other without needing the kind of I say
permission
from from these traditional bodies and
you know look at people that are dealing
with some uh with digital currencies and
crypto they've been trading amongst each
other whether it's with decentralized
exchanges or even with centralized
exchanges for what since 2008 2009 right
so that's like what 12 years and up
until four years ago The Regulators were
not necessarily involved in that and if
we're looking at nsds right now kids are
are trading amongst each other with you
know art and and uh and gaming nfts that
are worth hundreds of thousands of
dollars and The Regulators don't even
they're not even necessarily you know
aware of it I was I was um educating I
was a lecturing and uh and uh and um
kind of like teaching the Israeli tax
Authority
um about
um the metaverse and web 3 and how do
you tax these kinds of assets right
because
um you know when the tax authorities are
are pretty ahead in regards to
um uh you know to Innovation and
regulation I think they're one of the
I'd say the the most advanced
um Regulators right so they wanted to
understand how how do we tax
um these kinds of assets and and one of
the issues that that they that you know
needs to be solved is how do you tell a
13 year old kid that
holds um an nft that's worth two hundred
thousand dollars and he just traded it
for another nft 200 000 with his friends
that that's a taxable transaction right
he doesn't necessarily know that that's
attractive taxable to that transaction
and when you go to his parents they
don't even understand what he's doing
because he's in his room playing on the
computer right
so um so it raises a lot of questions
and and I think that if like who's gonna
be shaping this so on the one hand we
said we have the centralized entity but
on the other hand you have masses that
are communicating with each other and
kind of like creating a new reality
without asking anybody about it and the
reality is just being
um being created I'd say from the bottom
up right so
who's gonna be who's gonna be the one
that that decides where this is going
right so let's say the government's um
decide that they don't want
um digital currencies that they want to
ban it can they do it can they shut it
down can they shut down it's like asking
can they shut down the internet I'm not
sure about that right so um it's kind of
like you you know
the cat is outside of the sap right so
how are they going to stop it now so
who's actually going to be deciding on
how the future is going to be looking at
the regulators and the traditional
Finance or is it on the other hand
um you know the bottom-up and and the
masses that are understanding and saying
wait just a minute why is the data that
I'm creating
um being monetized by Tech Giants and
I'm not getting anything from that
wouldn't it make more sense for me to
hold my data in a digital wallet and
then decide who to sell it from and
maybe I don't even need to work because
the amount of data that I'm generating
when I monetize it could be more than
what I need for my for my personal
living okay and if a lot of people
understand that a lot of people realize
that then and then they decide to
migrate to solutions that give them this
kind of monetization abilities you know
then who's going to be deciding right is
it going to be the regulator be like
massive decided to behave in a certain
way
completely fascinating I really want to
thank you for taking this time and
sharing your your deep insights and um
it sounds like when one hand while
there's such a blue ocean that I love
the way that you're framing your
thinking around this strategically and
you're understanding the different
complexities
um different from from decision makers
to philosophies to different you know
big milestone decisions that we're gonna
have to make
um as a society of where we're headed
and it sounds like those are going to
have some significant implications on
the ways that that we're going to be
experiencing the world around us thank
you again for exactly for taking this
time to to meet with me and I and I
really am looking forward to continuing
following your work
thank you very much